one of the most
pivotal and crucial books written
in the history of islam and part of the
islamic library
very quickly we'll review the story
behind this book
the one of the teachers of ibn kathir
the mufassir and one of the students of
al-imam
zehabish the great muhaddith
went to on his way to hajj you know hajj
at that time was not it is now
you don't just jump on a plane take two
weeks off of work
you hedge and come back that's not how
it was back then
hajj was a huge endeavor
depending on where you're coming from
and
ibn kayim was coming from syria because
ibn al-qayyim
originates from dimeshk from the heart
of hashem
so it would take usually about
a month or two given
camping and how you have to gather food
and all of the things that are involved
in traveling in a caravan and caravans
would be very long
sometimes they would stretch miles long
and all of these people would stop and
make camp and share
food and so it takes a long time
to reach so this is why
hajj is placed in the center
of the sacred months
let's look at the way it is we have
right these three months go right
in succession
is right in the middle why
well it is so
that a person can travel safely
without the fear of war or retribution
to hajj during
and that a person can return
from hajj safely during that month
as well and get out of the region
sometimes a journey to hajj would take
four months
five months six months it depends
and decided that he would spend his time
writing a book about the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
what was his aim in this book
his aim in this book was to write
everything that he knew
about the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam
and he knew a lot
wrote five volumes from memory
quoting more than 200 sources
verbatim meaning word for word
from memory regarding everything having
to do with the prophet muhammad
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and the scholars of
islam have mentioned
that almost every
single aspect of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam has been written about
by ibn al-qayyim in zadil
imagine almost every single breath
that has been recorded by the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
that was breathed by the prophet
is contained in
almost the entirety of muslim imam
ahmed is found in zed
used to memorize muslim imam ahmed
this is one of the things that he had
memorized more than 36
000 narrations of the prophet
alaihi wasallam so he wrote this book
from memory
he spoke about everything how he dressed
how he walked who he knew
who he spoke to how he shaked hands
how his manners were how he ate what he
ate
what he was buried in the story of his
life after prophethood
everything and he began his book
and its five volumes the first volume
and the second volume are about the five
pillars of islam
right
ramadan and hajj those are the first two
volumes
the third volume is about the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's life
his biography the fourth volume
is all about the medicine of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
sometimes we see in book shops
the prophet's medicine have you ever
seen that book before
atl nebui this is actually the fourth
volume from zadil
he wrote that everything that the
prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam did
with regards to medicine
whether it be medicine of the soul
medicine of the heart
medicine of the mind medicine of the
body
and ibn ibm was a clinical doctor
as well a lot of people don't know that
about ibn al-qaeda
he was a trained doctor outside of the
field of islam
and so he wrote all about the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam's medicine
and then he wrote in alphabetical order
whatever the disease is
so for example for a headache soda you
look under saad
you see what the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam did
to treat headaches a lot of people don't
know that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam suffered from chronic
migraines
allah mentioned that sometimes more than
two weeks would go by
that the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam would not leave his home
because of the severity of his headache
imagine having a headache for two weeks
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
suffered from extreme
migraines and so one of the things that
he would do is he would tie
something around his head very very hard
to try to
tighten the veins and so forth
right this is one of the things that he
would do so there are many things that
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
did with regards to medicine
the fifth and final volume is all about
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam's
judgments
anything that he judged whether it be
divorce
whether it be marriage whether it be
kassas
murder any issue that he
judged in the position of a judge
that is what the fifth volume of zadil
ma'ad is about
and so imagine that he wrote all of this
from memory
and since the day that book was written
and completed
it reached all of the boundaries of the
muslim world
and it is now considered one of the main
references
of the sunnah of the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam if you want to know
something about the sunnah
is one of the main references
about the sunnah of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi that's just a quick
synopsis about this book
and how important it is we had reached
the
part speaking about salah janeza
how the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would make and perform solateal
so we are going to pick up from there
insha'allah
and we're going to continue from there
now the language may change between
arabic
and english based on whoever's in front
of me
if we get a lot of arabs i'm going to
start talking arabic
if we get a lot of falsely fellaheen i'm
going to start talking fellaini
if we get a lot of english speakers it's
going to be more english
whatever it is so excuse that inshaallah
but we want to
serve whoever comes to this class and we
want everybody to benefit
inshallah
[Silence]
is that usually the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would perform
outside of the masjid that is the sunnah
it was not his tradition to praise
inside the masjid
janaza usually the geneza would be
brought
and he would go outside of the masjid
there was also
a kind of
a kind of shack if you will or a kind of
canopy
that was placed outside of the masjid
that was known as the musa
where the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam would most usually praise
sallet in genesa
the geneza would be brought there and he
would pray solatul genesis there
sometimes however he may praise allah
inside the masjid
and he mentions here two incidences when
he prayed swallow
inside the masjid the first is
the janazah of suhailib
and also his brother sahil both of them
he prayed swallow on them inside the
masjid
right but that was not his tradition
the usual and the sunnah is that we pray
side of the masjid
unless there is some kind of
some kind of reason to not praise a
letter outside the masjid
for example chicago weather right
so it's raining it's snowing
it's freezing cold it's extremely
scorching hot
any of these things could be a reason
for us to praise falleth in genesis
inside the masjid
and here in the winter time you'll
notice those who attend the masjid a lot
in the winter time in the cold season
99 percent of the time we pray slalotl
janeza here inside the masjid
in the middle hall and that is correct
that is according to the sunnah
but in the summer time now we pray
outside in the parking lot and that is
how the prophet salallahu alaihi
wasallam did it
however it's important to note
that when the geneza is brought to the
masjid
right when the geneza is brought to the
and it is placed inside the masjid
and people are going to pray a regular
prayer before salah
janazah it should be placed in the back
of the masjid
this is a mistake that is often made
what am i talking about
so let's say we're going to pray so
let's vote right
and we have a geneza and we're going to
praise allah
inside the masjid but before
we pray salah we're going to pray salah
right the geneza should not be placed in
front
where everybody is praying towards the
janazah should be placed in the back
we make sure and then the janazah is
brought to the front
to make salah why why is that
limada the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam prohibited
making salah in a graveyard
and he prohibited graves in the masjid
what is the reason of the grave is it
the grave itself as a whole or is it the
dead person inside
it's a dead person inside correct he
said
this is one of the final things he said
in his life
before his death may the curse of allah
be
upon certain people of the people of the
book
they took the grave sites of their
prophets as
masajid places of worship the scholars
took from this that it is haram
to make salah towards a grave
it is haram to make salah in a masjid
that contains
a grave it is haram to make swala in a
graveyard
and a salah in the graveyard is
considered an
invalid prayer you have to redo it right
so the reason for this is that we are
making
we are making sujud this person that
is deceased should be in the back of the
masjid because of this
we put them behind us we make our salah
then we bring them forward
and we make solatill this is the way
that the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam
[Silence]
he says there is a narration in which
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
was narrated to have said
whoever prays in the masjid
then there is no problem with this this
narration is a weak
narration it is not authentic but its
meaning is correct
where do we cl where do we gather that
its meaning is correct
from the actions of the prophet
salallahu
and so sometimes if something is
correct you'll find the scholars of
islam will mention a weak narration to
bolster it
right so for example we see
that authentically
the prophet salallahu
right so we know from that that it's
permissible
ibn then mentions a narration that is
weak
but we know its meaning is correct right
so he says whoever prays
in the masjid then there is no blame
upon him
this narration is weak why did nilkaya
mention it
because its meaning is correct
right and this is something that ibn
kathir does a lot
in his tafsir he'll mention a meaning
then he'll mention a weak narration
and he'll say this narration is weak
that why did you mention it if the
narration is weak
well because the meaning is correct
right
and if the meaning is correct and the
meaning is
bolstered by the quran and sunnah this
raises the level of this weak narration
to be something that is
acceptable in meaning do we understand
that concept
is hadith
he says this narration is an acceptable
narration
where does he get that from because of
the actions of the prophets
and then he mentions some other things
regarding this narration
that do not concern us at this point
he also then mentions
another thing mentions here is that each
person is held hostage by his
or her debt
each person is held hostage by his or
her
debt and no one will be permitted to
enter
paradise until his debt is paid
right until his debt is paid what are we
talking about
debt you owe somebody money right
you owe somebody property but it's not
just that as well
it's other kinds of debt anything that
you owe
another person and that person did not
forgive you
then you are held hostage from entering
paradise
until it is paid for this reason
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would refuse to make salah janazah on
somebody who
had debt now i want everybody to listen
very closely okay
there is a difference between the
prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
making so on someone
and the companions making salat el
janeza on someone
okay just because the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam didn't praise saleh
doesn't mean that no salah was preyed
upon the person
it very well means that the rest of the
companions prayed solatill
but that person because of his debt or
because of
some other thing that that person did
he was deprived of the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam making
is going to be much more influential
than merely the companions of the allah
right and i'll give you an example
in sahih muslim a man
from the companions and this is
something that i'm sure many haven't
heard
of before and maybe is a little shocking
but you have to unders just because the
prophet salallahu salem was amongst the
companions
just because islam was at its height
doesn't mean that evil wasn't around
evil was around bad things happen
zina happened homosexuality happened
suicide happened but they were rare
contrary to our time now right
where good deeds are rare and the other
things are the norm
just because a prophet is present in a
time
does not completely eradicate
evil we should understand this
with his people correct the sea was
split and some scholars mentioned that
it was split into
12 different paths
one each path for each of the
tribes of bani israel
meaning it wasn't just split in half
just one path
it was split into 12 paths and each of
the tribes of bani israel
were able to trans
were able to transgress this
this sea right and take these paths
after seeing all of that and watching
firaoun be destroyed
musa salaam went to meet allah to get
the torah
how long was he gone for
how many days
how many days 40 days right
what's 40 days a drop in the bucket a
month and 10 days right
he was gone for 40 days and in those 40
days
haroon another messenger and another
prophet
was appointed and placed there with bani
israel
and they still manage to what they still
manage to
make an idol and worship it
so evil is around even if a prophet or
messenger
is present there will still be evil
this doesn't take away from the prophet
or messenger
but it does mean that evil is prevalent
always
throughout humanity that struggle is
always there
in sahih muslim
it's mentioned that a man shot himself
in the head with an
arrow a broad-headed arrow
what does this mean he shot himself in
the head with a broad-headed arrow
and he killed himself he committed
suicide on purpose
this wasn't a mistake it wasn't an
accident
he had committed suicide with a bow and
arrow just people do with guns
today
and the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said to the companions
he said take him and pray solaitel
geneza upon him
he himself did not pray solatel genesis
on that particular person why
because suicide is a major sin
and in order to deter people from that
when they see that oh if i take that
route the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam is not going to praise sallet
in geneza
then this will deter people from doing
that
right so he told the companions to pray
salah
which means the man is a muslim suicide
does not make you a catholic
and this is something that we have to
understand but it is a
major major sin in islam
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam refused to make sa
upon that person but he told the
companions
take him and pray salatin which means he
was given
all of the muslim rights he was bathed
he was shrouded
the companions gathered probably the
best of the companions
abu bakr and umar and uthman and ali and
abdul rahman bin auf and zaid bill and
ube and all of these great companions
right and they prayed so look him and
buried him even though he had committed
suicide
the same thing was the case with debt
when a pro when the prophet salallahu
alaihi wasallam would know
that a person had debt he would not pray
so let's
upon that person why
why is that to deter people
from not paying their
dues to other people
what does that mean
[Silence]
delaying paying a bill
delaying to pay someone you owe money to
and you have the ability to pay them
this is a type of oppression
he says so what's that mean
that means let's say mahmoud here
oh i owe him money
i owe him money and i have money i can
pay him right now if i wanted to
i have no other financial
responsibilities
for that particular money but i put him
off right
which is usually the case with human
beings right
human beings are good at give give me
give me and are not good at take
right so i put him off
i put him off i put him off every day
that i put him off and do not
pay him what he is owed i am i am
actually oppressing him
he has i am now committing a sin
against him right
because i am preventing him from what is
rightfully his
i am preventing him from what is
so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam in order to deter
people from getting into debt and then
dying without paying their dues
and leaving that debt to the family he
would not pray so let
geneza upon the person later on
this is at the beginning right this
is in the early days of
medina when when they were very poor
the muslims
we fast forward now to the seventh
eighth ninth year after hijrah
after fateh mecca after mecca was
conquered
conquered and after the muslims now
became
extremely wealthy in medina
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
abrogated that action
because he said
he said whoever leaves any wealth behind
it goes to his family but whoever leaves
any dead behind
i will be responsible for his debt
so after he became wealthy enough from
the
wars and from the war booty and the
spoils of war
and so forth and the economy of the
muslims in medina became very strong
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
would make salah
on everyone whether they had debt or not
because he would pay it
now there is a narration in which one of
the companions
had passed away
and the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam came to make solate
and he asked is this person
owe anybody any money and a man
spoke up and said yes he owes me such
and such
and so the prophet sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said i will not make salat in
genesis this is at the beginning
remember and so
one of the companions spoke
up and said i will pay his debt
so now his debt has what it has moved
from
him to this companion who has taken that
debt on
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said something that is chilling
it is very scary you want to know what
he said
he said that allah
he said now his skin now
as you said that and took the debt on
yourself
now his skin is finally beginning to
cool off
meaning that he was what he was being
held accountable with allah
at that moment for that debt that he had
not paid
so it's something to be taken seriously
we don't take loans for any reason
right and it's good to take a loan that
you
have to write it down you have to write
it
you have to put your debts in a will
because if you die and you owe someone
money
and nobody knows about it you're in a
big jam
and the only way that debt is going to
be rectified
is on the day of resurrection when you
meet that person and he takes from your
good deeds
none of us has enough good deeds to
spare
correct so we have to write it down we
have to let our loved one know
our loved ones know and it doesn't
matter how
big the corporation is that we owe money
to
sometimes in our
thought process we think oh you know
it's mastercard or it's whatever
you know what i mean they got enough
money they don't need my two hundred
dollars
they they you know it's the hospital
such and such hospital
they they're rich enough because it's
not about how rich or poor they are
it's not about what they need or don't
it's about what you
owe it's about your responsibilities
towards others
whether they're rich or poor that does
not have any bearing
on what you owe others right so debt
is something that is supposed to be
taken very seriously
there is a narration in a sahih
and this narration is also very chilling
right a man came to the prophet
sallallahu
alaihi wasallam and he asked him
as shaheed yoghurt
the person who dies a martyr in battle
are all of his sins forgiven
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said yes
and then the man left as he was leaving
he called him back
he said come back what did you ask
he said as shaheed
is his sins all forgiven when a person
dies as a martyr in battle
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
said
he said yes except for
death that is not forgiven
jibril just informed me of that
jibril just informed me of that so
something to be taken seriously
right whoever it is that you owe no
matter how much it is
either you owe somebody personally some
money
you make it clear to them hey if i die
what happens do you forgive me if i die
usually if it's your close friend your
muslim brother right
they're going to say if you die a liar
fairly
or if it's you know metropolitan
in new york or if it's you know
whatever
they're not going to say
right they're going to say we want our
money
or if it's a t or if it's whatever it is
right so we need to make sure that we
take this
issue seriously now so this is the
issue regarding how the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam would praise
soleit
or the person of debt now
if a person is a scholar
or if a person is extremely influential
right mainly scholars scholars now
people don't respect them they used
to
but during the great mighty days of
islam
scholars were above all kings
the only thing scholars didn't have were
thrones
and and crowns on their heads
scholars would be dressed in tatters and
they would be
kings amongst the people because
people would respect scholarship right
those days unfortunately are not
with us anymore they will come back
inshaallah
the prophet salallahu alaihi wasallam
told us
[Silence]
is
there were days when the muslim scholars
were kings
and today muslim scholars are not as
influential as they used to be
right you have some
18 year old 20 year old girl dancing
around on tick tock
or dancing around on instagram will have
7 million followers and a scholar will
have
10 or 20 people watch something that is
speaking about the hereafter right
jewels that will enter a person into
paradise
this is the days and time that we live
in unfortunately right now
and so in the time when
scholars were very influential they
would follow this sunnah as well
meaning if someone committed suicide or
if someone
were murdered someone or if someone was
a criminal
they would not make salat el geneza upon
the person
why to symbolize to the rest of the
people
that this is something that is wrong but
now we're not in that position we make
solate del genezzo on everyone
why do we make solatel janez on everyone
because
now we live in a time when muslims are
for the majority ignorant and illiterate
in their own religion
and it's important for us to be in a
state of extreme
tenderness towards each other
[Silence]
okay so now we're going to talk about
how many techbirds we make in solar
genes so i'm going to ask a question
how many times do we make takbir in
salah
four times right
but it's also been recorded
that on occasion the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam would
and it's also been recorded that he
would make six
tech virats
understood that the more influential
and the more important and the higher
rank
the person is the more tech virat that
person would get in their salah
so the people of badr he would make six
tek birat
any person who who was in the battle of
buddha and passed away
when he would pray salat he would he
would pray and make six tech birat
and he would make any of the companions
that would
pass away he would make five techbirds
and any of the rest of the taberin who
weren't companions he would make four
techbirds
there's ben mentioned that some of the
companions made up to seven tekbirat
and that is the most that has ever been
recorded
we make four tech birat right and that
is what we keep it at
we keep it at four tech virat and we
have something to say
after each takbira so we make the first
takbir
we recite surat al-fatiha the second
tech beer
we make a salah upon the prophet
sallallahu alaihi wasallam
the third takbir we make sincere dua for
the departed for the deceased
the fourth takbir we make dua for
ourselves and the general masses of the
muslims with brevity
and then we make tesleem i want you to
notice with me something
in the final moments here that we have
s
[Silence]
is
many people ask me is it permissible
for a person to make salat janeza
without
udu the answer is no that's
invalid a person must have
in order to make salat al-janezah
the prophet sallallahu alaihi wasallam
describes
saleh
[Silence]
he said the key to prayer is pahara
making and its entrance
is takbir and its exit is tesleem
so anything that has those
elements we consider to be salah
that needs to have now let's look at
salat el janesa does it have those
elements
it has a tech beer and it has a tesleem
correct therefore it must have a key
a proverbial key which is tahara
a person must be in a state of wudu
another thing that comes up often is
people will be
standing there and they'll say well
we're going to make salah
the masjid is right there can i make
tayemmum
the answer is no you can't make the
yemum if water is available correct
just you couldn't make taeyeon for
a regular salah if water
is available you have to make complete
wudu
this is something that i'm asked about a
lot and i wanted to make that clear
next week inshallah
allah subhanahu
[Silence]
foreign